by the way this is the queen's gambit
there there's been a little bit a little
bit of a misunderstanding as to what the
queen's gambit actually is
queen's game does not involve
sacrificing the queen
queen's gamut involves sacrificing the
pawn it's just on the queen's
side of the board that's what it's
called that way are you guys ready
for a game let's get this party on the
road
let's go
[Music]
so we're seeking a game and we're
playing gary ganoozi 1527
who has the same rating as me now i've
been playing the sicilian defense
recently in the speedrun he plays 92. uh
it's a bit of a weird move because it
obstructs the development of the bishop
but it is a fine move we're not going to
change our strategy on the basis of it
okay so he plays the move c3 white is
not developing his pieces he's moving a
bunch of pawns so what we need to do
with black is to develop our pieces
quickly
and strike in the center as early as
possible so first
we're going to develop our knight here
thank you pietro or siri for the prime
and we're going to attack a spawn on e4
now when i say strike in the center can
somebody remind me what move
specifically am i referring to
when i say strike in the center we want
to open up the center so that we can
exploit our lead in development
what we mean is the move d5 because well
it literally opens up the center and
we prepared the development of our
bishop okay so he plays f3
now there are several ways to go about
getting an advantage here we could
continue expanding in the center which
is what we're going to do let's continue
expanding in the center
with the movie five he goes bishop g5 to
pin our knight to our queen
we're going to unpin ourselves by
developing our bishop
and he's going to take so he's doing a
bunch of very dubious stuff here thank
you jay brain for the prime
why are we better here because we've got
superior central control he's played
this incredibly weakening move f3
and the reason it is weakening as we
know is because
it creates these openings around white's
king that are never desirable
and so for that reason if people are
thinking about pushing the pawn to d4 we
shouldn't do that
because that would close up the center
we don't want to close up the center we
want to open up the center so that we
can better exploit the weaknesses he's
created
so for the time being we're just going
to keep developing we're going to castle
our king put it into safety
we're going to see how he chooses to
develop and tailor our device and he
does our bidding for us he opens up the
center for us
now he's got a very weak pawn on d3 how
can we attack that pawn i'm looking for
two moves in particular
how can we put more pressure on this
pawn on d3
if we can play bishop f5 that's number
one what's number two
number two is rook d8 two for two guys
very nice
so let's get our rook to d8 why did i
not develop the bishop first i'll
explain that after the game there is a
specific reason that i'm playing rook d8
and not bishop f5
um okay let me just make a note of this
in my notebook
all right now part of the reason is
because i wanted to maintain the
flexibility
of developing this bishop and remember
our main campaign here our main plan is
to attack the pawn on d3 so can we
devise a development scheme for the
bishop
so that it would pressure the pawn on d3
we can no longer develop our bishop to
f5 this square is now covered
but how can we deploy our bishop
nonetheless to attack the pawn on d3
this will take two moves
we can play the move b6 this has the
added benefit of sort of
supporting our central pawn which is
always good
people associate the move v6 with the
fianchetto now he's gone c4 he's
panicked
why is the move c4 bad can somebody
explain to me from a positional
perspective
why is the move c4 bad what what square
does it weaken
and what can we put on that square look
at this juicy square and
in fact here's the thing guys we can
just play knight t4 we don't even have
to move our queen
because if he takes our queen then we
take his and that's gonna be a fork
against his king and his queen
so that's why i always stress don't have
those knee-jerk reactions
to your moves because sometimes you can
find something better if you don't make
any assumptions now we're just gonna
casually drop our queen back and uh
now we have another very instructive
move that we can make what do i see in
this position what i'm seeing
is this queen on c3 and i'm also seeing
our bishop on f6
they are at a standoff which means that
if this knight moves
we are going to be very close very close
to winning his queen but there's one
obstacle to that which is the pawn on e4
so let's push this pawn out of e5
and then if he takes the pawn where are
we going to move our knight
in order to win the queen that is called
a discovered attack or a discovered
check
we are going to put it on e2 and only on
e2 because if we put it anywhere else
then that's not going to be a move with
check which means that he's going to
have time to move his queen
he smartly this guy is quite good
decides to move his queen away now what
should we do now
we should play well there's a couple of
moves that we can play let's just push
our pawn to e3 let's keep expanding
keep dominating and look at this
beautiful pawn here right in his grill
uh he's got to move his knight away and
then we're just gonna move our bishop to
e5
and can somebody devise a method of now
supporting this pawn on e5 what are we
going to do most likely on the next move
in order to bring this pawn's neighbor
to its support
we don't need to do anything here let
him be the one to take our knight
yeah f5 let's go f5 let's push this
knight away from e4
and then if need be we can play f4 and
we can support
the pawn on e3 as much as possible
okay now what should we take with we
were talking about supporting the pawn
so with that in mind which piece or pawn
should we take on d4 with
we should definitely take with the pun
because what better way to support a
beautiful passpond which is a splinter
in his throat
than with another pawn another benefit
that i may draw to your
bring to your attention ladies and
gentlemen is that let's get get out of
here get out
get out of a g5 is the fact that we've
opened up the c file
why is that important because his king
is on the c file and why is it important
that his king is on the c file because
we can
add pressure to the pawn on c4 because
it's pinned
how can we do that how can we do that we
can play the move b5 we can start to
chip away at the defenses surrounding
his king
if we take on c4 and we're going to have
connected past pawns ooh
now this pawn is very weak how can we
attack this pawn
we can bring in another piece to attack
this fun on c5 it's a very typical way
to sort of exploit the drawback
yeah rook d5 bringing in the heavy
hitters
this is going to be pretty pretty over
i can't believe we have 4 000 viewers
right now welcome everybody
okay so he pins our rook we don't need
to rush in taking the pawn let's first
deploy our bishop to e6
also creating a standoff which we
threaten to exploit by taking on c5 of
the rook so he's best advised to move
his king out of the way
but it's not going to matter look at how
overwhelming our position is here all of
our pieces are in the game
this game is over thank you of mice and
men 7 for the prime
appreciate everybody's support we are on
the path to 4 000 subs which i can't
believe i'm saying
uh amazing stuff thank you guys we're
just gonna infiltrate with a rook to the
second rank
uh also this prepares the move e2
and oh we got enough we got more gifted
subs
uh we have more gifted subs from gem gem
taco another five big ones thank you so
much
are you guys ready for well
what do i always tell people in this
situation what i always tell people in
this situation is do not forget
to bring each and every one of your
pieces into the game
okay uh and which piece of ours
do you notice is not in the game
vietcong 47 thank you for the sub that's
definitely proffer
definitely the rook look at this
beautiful alekhine's gun we've
constructed
alakine's gun named after former world
champion alexander alakine from the
soviet union
i was talking a little bit earlier about
the mysterious circumstances surrounding
his death
rumor has it that he died by choking on
a piece of meat
can i procure the photos i can as he's
thinking i'm going to show you the scene
from alekhines well
i'll show that to you later but first in
such a position all of our pieces are
playing
what do we need to look for when all of
our pieces are playing we need to look
for tactics
what that means is we need to we need to
make the the position of our opponent's
king explode anonymous you're thinking
we can do that with rook takes
we could have also taken his bishop
there's a million ways to win here but
the simplest is just to
pave the way for our queen now to go
into c2
and deliver checkmate on a2 this is a
relatively simple combination that's
what a combination is it's a sequence of
moves that generally involves a
sacrifice
um and let me just find something
interesting for a second
if you guys can bear with me oh alekhine
yeah this is going to be hard to find
from this book but alexander alakin one
of the earliest world champions of chess
had a very interesting life story and an
interesting death story as well okay
mysteries it might be in this section if
you guys just give me a second
alekhine's death let's see if i can find
it here
yeah gary okay
recollection of malachi and alakan
alakan
yeah it's not going to be here
anyways i'll look for it later i'll look
for it later it's on the internet of
course
yeah i'll just find it on the internet
actually because it's pretty cool i
think for for a lot of people
chess history is kind of cool thank you
a bunch of numbers
for the sub to make it but i also
shouldn't show photos of like dead
people
uh so maybe we'll do that later thank
you so much for the sub
um i don't know about that i think we
got we got some younger members of the
audience
okay so what i normally do after playing
a game like this i usually play in
batches of
two or three but sometimes when a game
is particularly rich
i i go through it immediately right and
i answer
everybody's questions about the game i
want to make sure everybody's included
and i want to make sure no matter what
level you are you learn and you you
don't feel
shy about asking questions that's the
environment that we're trying to build
in this community
okay so let's quickly go over this game
and maybe play one more
basically what our opponent was not
doing in the opening and a lot of people
that at this rating range right we're
1500 and i think ux algorithms for the
prime
are um they play these moves that are
just
subpar right he's not developing his
pieces he's putting his pawns on weird
squares and so what we do in return is
we just
grab control of the center while also
developing
our pieces to very good squares and
he played bishop g5 pinning our knight
to our queen what is a pin
a pin is when a piece of lesser value
stands behind a piece of
higher value and there's an opponent's
piece that's skewering both of them
uh so we can't move essentially we
cannot move the knight without losing
our queen
there are exceptions to the rule
sometimes you can move a pin piece for
several reasons and so and pin ourselves
and he took enough sticks that's a bad
move
this violates the principle of not
moving a piece more than once in the
opening
but there's no need for him to trade
that bishop in fact he now creates a lot
of weaknesses
around his dark squares which are even
further weakened by the fact that he
doesn't have a dark squared bishop
anymore
so he should have probably just tried to
develop his pieces at least made an
attempt to do so
um but but by not doing that he
exacerbated the situation and he further
exacerbated by taking on d5
why was this move bad because it opened
up the center for us
because we have elite development that's
very important
now the move b6 deploying our bishop to
a6
in order to attack the pawn on d3 how do
we find this move well we want to
identify the
main weaknesses in our opponent's
position we want to try to exploit them
right so here
we look at the pawn on d3 clearly it's
very weak we have a lot of our pieces
staring at it
another good way to identify weaknesses
look for pawns that cannot be defended
by any other puns if you see a pawn
and you notice that it cannot be
defended by any other puns
then chances are you want to pile up on
it right because your opponent is going
to have to waste
peace resources to uh to defend it
and instead he decided to shut down the
potential of bishop a6 but in return
he he created this massive hole on d4
and um now we played the very important
move e4 opening up the skewer
possibility against his queen
again if he takes on e4 we give a check
this
check sacrifices the knight but it
exposes the attack on his queen and we
win a queen
console asks why not bishop f5 in which
position
may i ask yeah so bishop f5 why not
uh because after knight e4 he basically
shuts down the bishop right this knight
on e4 acts as kind of a rock
and the bishop loses its effectiveness
that's the reason why
we wanted to deploy our bishop through
a6 and not through f5 thank you internet
police
for the two months really appreciate it
man these
subs are incredible
mm-hmm you guys appreciate it very much
and basically that's how we won the game
after that he we drove our pawn into e3
we supported it with oh we got five
more subs from gem gem taco incredible
this level of support is extraordinary
thank you gem jam
we've got right about the same amount of
subs as viewers and that's saying
something
thank you so much also i know you took
with a seat button to open the file but
what would what would have been the
advantages of taking on the pawn on
before with the bishop instead of the
pawn
yeah that's a great question so another
critical moment occurred here right
we could have also taken with the bishop
it's one of those cases where everything
is good
the issue is it keeps the position a
little bit closed right by taking with
the pawn we open up that
artery to his king which we're able to
exploit by playing b5
here white can sort of keep things close
together
and the board is frozen i see that sorry
about that folks
it's been a persistent glitch recently
what i was explaining is that
there is a reason that we took on d4
with a pawn and we did that in order to
open the c file
we could have also taken with the bishop
this would have created a very strong
outpost for the bishop
but it would have kept the position a
little bit closed uh which
which is not in our favor because his
position is so crippled in general
but we could have played a6b5 for it to
chip away
at the queen side this is also quite
overwhelming for black
okay was bishop f4 followed by it to a
bad move yeah so we could have also we
could have done that thank you oh
zan holy smokes stand 13 with 1200 bits
uh we could have tried to set him up
here
by playing bishop f oh that would have
been an interesting move because we
attacked the knight
and we prepared a discovered attack with
e2
but knight h3 would have followed and he
would have attacked the bishop that's
giving that
attack initially at the end of the day
we have an extra rook for
a night which which is called an extra
exchange but that's not the best that we
can do
that's just not the best that we can do
and i want to encourage people that when
you're look when you're thinking about a
position
there's two pieces of advice that i have
to share the first is
if you have two moves that you want to
play one move followed by another move
you always have to ask yourself what
happens if i play the second move
first and in this case what if we play
e2 first
we sacrifice the pawn and only now do we
go bishop f4 and now
we simply win his night we we end up up
a p so that would have been a fantastic
move
the second thing is do not cash in too
soon okay
there's some positions where people see
oh i can win a pawn i can win a night
but the reality is you should always be
you should always
be aiming for the most ambitious outcome
of any position do we want to just win a
measly exchange sure absolutely not we
want to go for more than that we want to
go for checkmate
so you want to ask yourself what am i
going for in a particular position
that can help you not cash in too soon
okay
let's play one more let's play one more
unless anybody has any questions because
i want to keep things dynamic but we're
already up to 15 35 we're up to a very
solid rating
and we're moving our way up to 1600
all right let's go why i'm happy
to provide okay we're playing a 1700
that's a pretty serious opponent
let's play the italian which i've been
playing okay so d6 is a very calm move
it's also not a great one because it
obstructs the development of the bishop
those of you have been watching the
speed run how do i like to proceed in
this position
how do i like to proceed in this
position how do we occupy the center
well there's two ways to do that we can
go d4 immediately
or the alternative as people are
suggesting is to prepare the move d4
with c3
i personally like to occupy the center
with pawns
so that's sort of my
general um that's sort of my general
approach and so we can just go d4 i
don't really care about his spin i mean
it's it's just totally fine
and now we have a look at this beautiful
pawn center that we have
uh this pin is annoying but it's nothing
that we can't deal with because we've
developed our bishop to a very nice
square where it's sort of
pressuring the f7 pawn okay so our
opponent decides to pressure
two things at once which one is the most
important to defend
well it's clearly the d4 pawn we need to
lend some support to this d4 pawn
how do we do that while developing one
of our pieces
how do we do that while developing one
of our pieces we can play bishop to e3
exactly
why are we not afraid of bishop takes f3
doesn't this ruin our pawn structure
well
it's exactly what he's wondering that's
a very typical mistake at this level
pawn structure is this sort of
irresistible you know i don't know it's
it's like the scent
that people fall for but the reality is
it doesn't tell the whole story
because if you look at our pawn
structure right the pawn on f3
may look ugly but the reality is it
supports the pawn on e4 so this is a
pretty robust pawn chain
the second thing is we have an
incredibly not only do we have an
incredibly strong center but we have a
lead in development
and we have two bishops and furthermore
the light scored bishop is uncontested
so by just developing our pieces we're
going to get a tremendous initiative
here we can also repurpose this pawn
and push it forward and prepare the pawn
break e5
i could uh jose but a queen shade would
would be not desirable because he's
underdeveloped that would help him mask
the problem of his underdevelopment
let's centralize our knight which i like
to do
quite frequently queen b3 would have
also been possible and it
it is possible well let's just bring our
pieces into goods onto good squares i'm
going to bring the rook onto this
semi-open file just so it can pressure
the knight later on let's see what he
does
let's see what mr victor does
and he goes knight f6 and that would be
a good time for queen b3
we can definitely set up some stuff
along that file
but um yeah our king is fine in the
center i i think then this is where
people have to understand
you don't you're not obliged to castle
uh
there's no higher authority that forces
you to castle if your king is safe in
the center
then your king is safe in the center
okay and very often it is and very often
i see people rushing to castle
when you could just keep your king in
the center for the time later on if we
need to castle okay we can castle here
we can tuck our king away on h1 and it's
still going to be safe but you don't
need a castle yeah black doesn't have
any pieces developed
okay we're going to play bishop takes d5
now what are we attacking here
boom boom we're attacking this pawn and
that actually is checkmate
and we're attacking the pawn on b7 sort
of morphe style
he has no way of develop of defending
both of them at the same time he is
busted
and he runs into checkmate can somebody
tell me it's checkman in two moves
this is the pattern that you guys should
definitely remember
boom
and king and queen e6 sending in the
queen and guess what guys
the reason i put the rook on c1 i knew
this rook would be good and it is it's
the key instrument and why this is
checkmate the king cannot escape on c6
because
we put a rook on c1 so when you bring
your pieces into good squares you
get rewarded for that even if i didn't
know that this would happen exactly
i didn't calculate this line okay i want
to be very clear but
i know that when i put pieces on good
squares good things tend to happen
okay so what happened in this game
um what happened in this game is very
simple
he started badly by playing d6 that's
just not a very active move it
kills the development of this bishop and
the reason i like c3 is not only that it
prepares d4
and supports that with the pawn but also
it opens up this avenue for our queen
where i can simultaneously attack two
pawns at the same time we could have
even done that
right up here we could have gone queen
b3 we could have forked
the two pawns but i decided to sort of
stick to the general strategy sorry
about that
decided to stick to the general strategy
of playing d4
and his main mistake was this move
bishop takes f3 he should have probably
either castled long maybe he should have
developed his knight
but instead he took on f3 which does our
bidding for us and he continued to waste
time there's no need to play a6 here
he can't afford these kinds of moves he
falls further behind the development
and that's why we burned him here here
rook c1 bringing the rook into the game
and then queen b3 is a very simple move
knight a say one second
thought i smelled some smoke knight a5
is also possible
but then we can take on f6 and follow up
with what move loose pieces drop off
which means that one move becomes
possible here
what move becomes possible in this
position it's simply queen a4 check
that's a fork
and if he drops his knife back to c6 we
can go d5
and by the way if he goes b5 trying to
counter fork
you can just take on b5 remember the
rook on a8 that's a very important piece
to pay attention to because
you know it often remains undefended in
these kinds of positions
boom boom the game is basically over
that's how we won the game he of course
well the lesser evil probably would have
been to defend this pawn although he is
completely lost
um and aha another five gifted from gem
jam taco
this is extraordinary thank you gem jim
35.99
lucky subscribers to the channel
and i am the truly lucky one that is
incredible
thank you thank you jim jim
and uh this nighttime hype is real we've
got 3 500 viewers
hope everyone's enjoying and oh
here we go we got a bunch of numbers
gifting five subs
everybody jumping on the train thank you
a bunch of numbers for the five
as well to no friction amc am mcdonald's
hs 74 hyde reception and jacobian 100
bits
curious oh my god this is unbelievable
happy thanksgiving ladies and gentlemen
curious chimpanzee another five
man i i have a feeling that people like
the speed run
thank you so much curious chimpanzee
another five gifted
okay so are there any questions about
this game or should we move
on to the next one this community
is incredible 3609
no say decios with the
with a prime and gains train 13 with the
with the uh tier one with the seven
months thank you man
all right let's go
let's go again and i didn't castle again
remember
you don't always have to castle that
that's not a rule of chess
why not queenside castle yeah i'll
answer that hey man the hero of today
man broughty caro down to 33.50
uh he's my boy okay so
this guy plays the perk defense which is
d6 and g6 this is called the perk
and the reason that the perk gets a bit
of a bad rap is because
obviously our opponent has granted us
control of the center
and in the perk one of white's key
strategies thank you mujo a for the
prime
one of the key strategies in the perk is
for white to castle queen side
the reason the white castle's queen side
has stephen stromboli gifting five subs
again
holy smokes thank you man is because we
want to attack
on the king side and we can't really
attack on the king's side if that's
where we're castled
so in order to castle queenside we have
to clear clear the path for the king to
come to c1
we do that by positioning our bishop and
our queen on d2 and e3
there's an added benefit to doing this
what is that added benefit what can we
do
with this battery thank you steven
stromboli for keeping the hype going
incredible stuff here we can play the
move bishop h6 and we can
knock out forcefully forcefully knock
out
our opponent's strongest piece his
bishop that's the piece that's going to
supervise the attack but we don't need
to do it yet
we are under no obligation to hurry with
trading on g7 how do we start the attack
on the king side how do we rip
open the files and the avenues on the
king side what do we do
let's go with h4 we got to take the
hammer to black's position otherwise
we're not going to have the necessary
you know steven stromboli subbing
himself
now it's very important to
point to a couple of things here okay
knight h5 what do we do now
how do we get rid of his knight
how do we get rid of it yeah g4 get out
of here get out
we don't want him here let's go get out
of here back to f6
and then we can actually just play h5
and keep attacking
we also but but we're not going to do
that we're going to play a little bit
more in a measured
fashion we're going to play
in more measured fashion here i want to
defend this pawn i don't want to let his
knight if
if he comes back to f6 i don't want to
let his knight capture g4 that
leads to some complications we're just
going to play the move f3
to defend that pawn and then we're going
to play h5
yeah so we're just chasing his knight
away and what is our ultimate goal in a
position like this our ultimate goal
is to open up the h file because that's
the artery
to black's king otherwise we're not
going to get to black's king
uh okay so let's play f3 i could have
also sacrificed upon as men is
indicating but
i want to sort of show the importance of
patience when you're attacking and then
sometimes eliminating
okay so what do we do here how do we
conduct ourselves in the center do we
want the center to be open or do we want
the center to be closed
given that we're attacking on the king
side
we certainly want the center to be
closed
why do we want the center to be closed
because if the center is closed then
it's easier for us to attack on the
king's side that's how you want to
reason
when it comes to opening or closing the
center it's not rocket science right if
you're attacking on one side of the
board
and the center is open there's a lot of
there's a lot of stuff going on in the
center
you're not going to have the attention
necessary to pay to the the side that
you're attacking on
when the center is closed you buy
yourself a bunch of time
and now we once again transition back to
our plan of opening up the king side
okay
and you guys are doing great all right
yeah people zlo is very very high i have
to say
no this is awesome okay so he goes g5
he's trying to keep things as closed as
possible what do we do with the spawn
what should we take it with and this is
just the winning move
yeah absolutely queen takes
we threaten checkmate how does he defend
the bishop he has only one way of doing
that he's got to drop his knight back
but then he gives up his queen and we're
gonna have an extra queen
and we're gonna be winning oh he does
this okay
now we could take with a rook we could
but but let's take with the queen i want
to preserve
the queens on the board even though i
personally would have taken with the
rook because that would have won a
second piece
but i want to i want to take the hammer
to him thank you jam jam for another
thousand bits
wow non-stop
non-stop all right um
so let's see what black does here he's
down a piece he's getting crushed along
the h
file and he finds a good move i actually
underestimated this move he brings his
queen into the defense
it's fine we're still up a piece now
what do we do here how do we
re-structure our pieces well we need
we need fresh blood and we need to not
forget to develop our pieces and
complete our development so let's
complete our development let's castle
and then one thing that we can do is we
could position this night we could send
it over to this weak square on f5
to open up the g file yeah let's do it
let's get this knight all the way to f5
to dislodge the queen or if he takes on
f5
we open up another file we can
potentially later
let's stop the pawn from progressing any
further by the way he's doing a good job
here he's trying his best
to stir things up on the queen side
problem for him is it's not fast enough
okay not even close
so this is called a maneuver and by
maneuvering the knight to f5
we either force him to trade and open up
the g file we're going to put a rook on
the g
file and we're going to do that by
moving our bishop out of the way and
taking a spawn
there's no stopping rook g1 the rook g1
is going to be absolutely crushing
um this game is over because he's either
going to lose his queen or get
checkmated or both
most probably both and um
great so that was a nice game that was a
nice attack that was a very traditional
perk attack and there was nothing
extraordinary about it we just sort of
did
the things that that we're supposed to
do and then we won
okay um let's see
how black well let's see if our opponent
well we're king h8 whoops oh it was a
metal slip guys
i meant to put the other rook on g1 but
let's turn this into something good
shall we it doesn't matter we can always
just move my rook back to h1
and he's basically gonna have to move
his queen back to g7
i guess he can play h6 but yeah so he
finds a way to prolong the game
um now let's just say let's trade queens
and win the game that way this is not
the best but this is fine because now
we're actually still checkmating him
even though it's the end game
we have checkmate in two moves we have
checkmate and two moves can somebody
spot it
f6 we can check his king force it
backward and deliver mate
on h8 so even though we traded queens it
doesn't matter it's still mate
we're still in good shape okay
great checkmate good game okay
um so what happened in this game
how could he have how should he have
defended should i mean does the perk
lose no it doesn't
it certainly doesn't lose castles is
already i think according to modern
theory and accurate because
it walks right into this attack right it
walks right into
the heart of white's attack which is to
play bishop h6 and h4h5
now what should he have done i think
what black should have done
is immediately tried to assault our
center because the faster
black can get to the center the harder
it is for us
to continue the attack on the king side
so for example
if we stubbornly play h4 and he puts his
knight on c6
then he can already take our bishop and
he can take our pawn
and this introduces some intrigue into
the position because he's now
threatening to capture on c2
so this is you know this is a little bit
complex
so we need to pay attention to to the
center we maybe need to castle
and then maybe he strikes with e5 so
something like this to try to
you know to try to mix things up a
little bit in the center
and distract white's attention from the
attack that's what he should have done
how do you respond to nitro iv we had a
question about this move
we can just move the bishop out to g5 i
certainly don't want to give it away
this bishop is precisely the instrument
that's allowing us to attack with the
greatest possible strength
so we would keep it on h4 on g3
and then chase the knight away from g4
okay
why not c5 before knight c6 yeah that is
also possible you can go
he goes you can go c5 there thank you
yar 33 for the six months
appreciate it
i've played the perk myself here comes
h4 g4
attacking his knight get out of here f3
to defend the pawn and now the key move
in the whole game to close the center
right if we kept the center open let's
say we gone h5 instead
then after e takes d4 things already
gets super complicated we can't take on
d4 right remember our bishop is hanging
so we're gonna have to manage this new
opening of the center with
the fact that we're trying to attack why
not bishop b2 instead of f4 well we
never played f4
oh you mean why not f4 so this is the
austrian attack
the austrian attack is another variation
of the perk where white
occupies the center in as aggressive of
a way as possible
very much possible vary this is the main
line
um yeah knight g4 is possible as i
explained but
uh we can we can keep this bishop safe
by by
sort of maneuvering it along along this
path
over here okay
so that's how you attack in the perk you
just go bishop h6h4 and
it's as easy as one two three by the way
if he would have moved his knight back
to e8
we would have just captured on d8 okay
and and that would have been a free
queen
probably that was a little bit more
resilient than what he ended up doing
but um it's still completely lost
why can't he just trade his bishop for
yours well he can but that's the entire
point
of what we're trying to do here when he
trades his bishop for ours
not only does he no longer have this
very crucial piece on g7 which was
skewering sort of attacking our position
the second thing is if you look at his
king just visually it's weak right and
all that remains for us is not to open
up the h file
and we're going to have uh very very
good attacking chances